Conservatives should care about the 2020
decennial census. For one, it's mandated
in the US Constitution. And right up top.
Fidelity to the Constitution implies
fidelity to a fair and accurate census.
In addition, the census is critical to
American business. The best way for a
free market to work efficiently and
fairly is for businesses of every size
to have access to accurate information
to help them make critical decisions. If
conservatives want businesses to make
the best decisions possible, they should
want a fair and accurate census. A major
threat to the accuracy of the census is
underfunding. Why? Due to rhetoric coming
from Washington, members of some
immigrant and minority communities have
already shown concern about answering
census questions. The commerce
secretary's unfortunate decision to
include a citizenship question makes
matters worse. The more reluctant people
are to answer the survey, the more money
census will have to spend to get their
answers. In addition, census is
employing new technologies for the 2020
count that will save taxpayers money in
the long run, but those technologies need
to be tested and protected against
threats. An accurate census is in all our
interests. Congress needs to step up.
What do you think about the 2020 census and the citizenship question? Let us know in your
comments. Also, let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds, and be sure to like and
subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.